[Music]
in distracted driving news Ono submitted
by Joe for president 2018 I don't wanna
be no president I want to be a month
like a dictator there's a difference
UK police are warning drivers that they
could lose their license if they vape
while driving babe while driving you
mean like we babe or like nicotine is it
cuz it blocks their view
Oh gas smoke on that kind of vaping when
it turns into a big [ __ ] I did wonder
that [ __ ] because I have a friend who
vapes through a really big thing and as
he's driving I can't even I can't see
bro like chill with that [ __ ]
he rolls down the window but it doesn't
matter he didn't oh yeah I do like the
smell though yeah it smells great
it's like Oh what is that so mouths are
really danced like I can see them like
at Disneyland owner and they're just
babe in and then when they're walking
away that cloud is still hanging in
there who's crazy even in cars you see
it I'm like four cars down and I just
see this big ass yeah because the ones
that like a lot of people are using are
the ones that are made for entertainment
purposes right the one that you can do
tricks
yeah cuz the regular ones is just wisps
it's not really much you know what I
mean but those are people who are trying
to get off cigarettes they have a higher
light nicotine hit but those [ __ ]
huge ones are just there to like it's
like a bong hit have you seen
professional like it's crazy they'll
make like rings yeah yeah and Oh like
throw things in between and make designs
where's the funny [ __ ] though when
somebody tells me that's what they do
I'm like get away from me for a living
huh well they're just like what do you
do this like it's like well I like to do
like smoke tricks or do something cool
bro yeah and I'm like alright well and
they're like what do you do and you're
like I talk to myself to again not
anymore
I am now on my credit a filmmaker
yeah so the UK police they're saying
that they will take licenses away or
give penalties I mean they should just
[ __ ] arrest people that vape because
it's just douchey so yeah they should
give him a
arrests believe in disguise points on
your license and stuff if they catch you
baby for that exact same reason the fact
that the cloud just blocks your view I
think it's douchey when people just blow
smoke without like considering people
behind you I don't care if you're
[ __ ] beat being here especially well
you don't tell us what the flavor is
because I don't want smell that [ __ ] if
I don't know it's like when people use
their windchill wipers Luud purpose but
sometimes I can't see anything and I
need to use it yeah all right so if I
see the cars far behind me I'm like okay
cool this yeah I'll do it at a stop sign
if I really have to do it I want
somebody to make this thing where you
could attach an LED light in the back
that says my bad do I do that or I'll
say I'll turn on my emergency lights
just like blink a couple times and then
turn on a universal signal cuz I just
want one that just has an LED thing of
my own face going like this like they
have an emoji face see I'd be back yeah
we should have better ways of
communicating like hey didn't mean to be
a dick but if people don't even use
their [ __ ] blinkers what they're not
gonna use that because sometimes like
when I'm driving and I it's like it's
already in heavy traffic so I have to
even do this it's too much work hey so
actually if your windows rolled you mean
we're driving a Tesla and it's driving
by itself yeah sometimes
Thank You element now and it just broke
down the other day and I got it fixed
again it's in the garage
just let it chill it cuz I got this bad
boy right here you can if you like go
ahead okay any Belka borrow my car good
legs didn't cause me to guess it's true
gotta say I gotta give my car back in a
couple months
why Oh Alize at least it I can't wait to
get because I thought I'd be tired by
this is the first time were
I think I'm gonna part a wave like with
just great memories I ever be attached
to material things but it's just it
feels so good driving it's don't know
what to though I bet you it's because
that was the first time you got a good
dope car it was your first one yeah it
was the one that I wanted yeah I've been
thinking about what you're getting I've
been looking at the Range Rover Sport
cuz I just love the brand Range Rover
and Jaguar living in LA like I really
don't need a car what yeah what what do
you mean downtown LA yeah yeah I walk
everywhere and I heard I can over the
one place you do need a car because you
have to get to all these different parts
of it and there's not if I didn't have a
car and I just had like some sort of
uber membership and I can guarantee that
like my ubers are always dope I would be
super down the car this is what I think
uber should do if they have some way to
make money off of this if there was like
an uber members yeah only cost 800 bucks
a month I would do it I would you know
because look it's unlimited rights cuz
Mike my carb tab is way over eight
hundred bucks a month just heard of
Tesla huh yeah so if I pay 800 bucks a
month and anybody could pick me up at
any time I'm doing it wasn't bad saying
that he has something like that he
dropped G's a month yeah well he can
yeah he's in every single nut flew so
I'm like trying flipping the channel
because shows like every show you like
in every [ __ ] thing and they're rated
really high yeah first of all I think
Andrew Bachelor is one of the most
talented soon as we met him before he
came up on binary humble - yeah number
super-nice but as somebody who has I saw
like as a supporter I watched all the
movies I think they all suck he he's
very talented and humble
he just doesn't attach himself to the
right projects but that's also part of
the strategy that strategy is probably
just to like I'm gonna just saturate the
market get in everyone everyone's gonna
know my name so it's a it's a primary
strategic move I like that baby sitter
wanna use I did not like that okay
trust me I go in these he's wanting to
like everything he does he's a friend of
course
I want to support my honey there's also
some like one movie it was that time
travel movie one I liked the people in
it and I didn't like that movie are you
talking about a time machine
no that one's great right now it's like
maybe you haven't seen it was with uh
what's-his-name and yeah how we met yeah
that one was terrible
yeah I know but I like Adam Devine and I
like batch I like that so I like the
people in it it just wasn't that one was
that was the one Ellis hyped up for the
most other he's gonna finally be in one
that's gonna match up to his caliber the
trailer looks good it was bad I can't
say [ __ ] cuz I'm in nothing but JK news
yeah but when I was reading this I
started thinking about distractions when
you try it dude I do my mascara while
I'm driving I actually do you also
masturbate when you drive I mean
honestly the only time I've ever been in
an accident was when I was completely
looking at the road I just zone out when
I look at you guys need a Tesla bad I'll
help you out a lot I'm like a great
moment of me driver I can drive me too
this is bearable to have on recording I
don't drive with my name you know I I
was actually thinking about just keeping
the Tesla because I found out that if
you the Tesla that I have right now it
has free charging for the life of it if
I get another Tesla it won't free
charging what do you mean I can go to
any Tesla supercharger and I could
charge it for free oh because of like it
you got it your early adopters the other
ones they so from here on out if you get
a Tesla you actually have to pay for
charging so that's like the prius with
the you can go in the carpool lane but
it does make sense because they're
they're using that revenue to open up
more electric chargers because there
aren't enough and on top of that the
purpose of the tesla charger was for
people to use it at home you know so
it's for the convenience sake but then
people are so [ __ ] cheap they're
trying to go to these charges and
they're waiting lines and lines for it
so they're like biggest talent it
doesn't make any sense
and so it's like a very nominal female
that's why I would never I just don't
want to Tesla I love my Honda Hybrid
that's my favorite car I've ever owned
yeah I mean hybrids are great - I'm
gonna cycle at 40 miles to the [ __ ]
gallon yeah you know you're rarely ever
like I feel for gas like every six weeks
I walk so much now in LA I think I try
my best to avoid driving so driving to
me is like oh if I have to do it just
get rid of the cars if there's no
traffic I like driving I'd be done with
that too that means like full stop
traffic I feel like I'm about to go
crazy
wait but you'd rather be a passenger in
full stop traffic yeah dude not me I
love to get to be on your phone and do
so you could work like that's the one
thing I liked about uber like sometimes
like you know you get so busy and you
kind of like neglect your social media a
little bit but then the times like that
if I was being driven somewhere in that
ten minutes I could do a post or I can
do like being the be more on top of like
the little stuff when you're driving you
can't do those things so like people do
that's good then you won't text and
drive and die yeah I never mess with my
phone like a text look at Instagram do
all kinds of stuff on driving yeah I can
do that when you should I know I should
so I stopped because I curved my my
wheels twice is that why didn't know why
the one time I do remember why are you
always revealing [ __ ] on JK news and
then you lie at home you're like I don't
know why but then it comes out great
conversation you forget about the demon
sitting next to you or what really
happens is he forgets in the moment yeah
and then he remembers exactly I get
inspired because I forgot Liars a liar's
like I'll forget a forgetter is not a
liar yeah well forget it forget it
forget everything forget
not as catchy yeah forget to say too
[Music]